est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous craignez une
large défaite pour la république en
marche non je ne parlerai absolument pas
de défaite
je pense que ces élections nous ne
pouvions pas les perdre et nous pouvions
pas les gagner pour beaucoup de raisons
la première raison c'est que vous savez
comme moi que le collège électoral est
un collège formatés par les formations
politiques il y à une première étape qui
a été l'étape des présidentielles et des
législatives
ce sont les citoyens qui ont décidé les
citoyens ont décidé de la comment dire
de la reconfiguration delà de l'image
politique d'un pays ici pour le moment
ce qui se passe c'est le dernier sursaut
finalement dumont ancien à mon avis
c'est le dernier sursaut du monde ancien
parce que les citoyens veulent cette
recomposition et n'est pas terminé
puisque ce qui sortirait le camembert
qui sortira ce soir ne sera pas le même
de celui qui sortira le 2 puisqu'il va
il ya le cumul des mandats et que
certains sénateurs vont devoir choisir
puis quand on va configurer les groupes
il va y avoir des mouvements d'un groupe
à l'autre
à l'évidence il va y avoir des
mouvements du groupe socialiste il y a
des je connais des socialistes
progressistes de réformistes
sociaux-démocrates qui iront dans le
groupe à république en marche c'est sûr
c'est certain ça mettez-vous des meubles
à quantifier vous non non je n'ai pas
quantifié je ne fais pas de projection
je ne donne pas de chiffres français
pour vous c'est une certitude il y en
aura parce que ce n'est pas possible
nous ne vont pas pouvoir cohabiter
on ne peut pas cohabiter en souhaitant
le succès du présent la république et en
souhaitant aux côtés être dans
l'opposition
donc il va y avoir un moment donné une
fracture sur la question de la droite
notre meilleure alliée ça va être
monsieur wauquiez parce que mes
collègues de droite je les connais et
ils ce sont des républicains des vrais
républicains au sens république
pas au sens partisan et parce qu'ils
sont des vrais républicains ils ne
supporteront pas la porosité avec le
front national
donc là la reconfiguration la
recomposition politique du pays
elle est en marche et
irréversible